uh I hope if you're looking to ensure
high quality data you're in the right
place our next talk is on returns to
data Inferno are the seven layers of
data testing hell still relevant we're
joining here today by Daniel funer and
data engineer at zabia let's give him a
round a warm Round of Applause as a
welcome all right hello everybody uh
it's 2:30ish on a Friday afternoon so
I'm really happy to see so many people
still ready and willing take this
journey back into hell with me uh we're
going to be taking a look at data's
Inferno um and seeing if those seven
layers of data testing hell are still
relevant so quick show of hands who here
knows what data in data's Inferno is has
seen the talk heard the talk okay a few
hands okay great uh then you'll also get
a bit of History lesson of uh what we
did back in 2017
2018 uh firstly little bit about me so
I'm a data engineer ER exia data um I
was thinking about what to put on this
slide so I figured well I could just
tell you what I like so I like
Automation and I like robust data
pipelines and I like memes uh it might
show on my slides sorry um what I don't
like bad data manual processes and data
managed in Excel sheets um I've been uh
confronted with that too often
unfortunately um so for the uninitiated
of which we have quite a few here so D
is Inferno was a Meetup and a conference
talk back in 2017 and 18 um that I I
gave with a colleague at the time John
Mueller shout out to John he's not here
today um but he was my my partner in
crime on this uh we had a blog post to
accompanying it to accompany it and a
GitHub repo as well with some examples
of how we actually did this uh on a
dummy data set um essentially it was an
an explanation of how we approach
dealing with really bad quality data um
so we're going to take a look at that
today and see uh what Still Remains of
that six years old um so as I said it is
a story about DEA quality so to give you
a bit of context what we were dealing
with at the time was I was working at
ING a major Bank in the Netherlands but
also outside of the Netherlands and we
were trying to build a really awesome
data driven application and also data
science models artificial intelligence
models on top of that you know large
data set um the said the biggest one was
the transactions so payment transactions
you know when you go into the
supermarket and pay for something uh and
we were doing some interesting analytics
on that um but garbage in garbage out
right the cliche almost uh it was hard
to work with the data we had some real
quality issues and getting making sure
that the data made sense um anecdotally
at some point we decided that the top
100 or 1,000 companies in the world in
terms of profits were all
Hungarian why were they all hung and
well somebody did a bad currency
conversion somewhere along the way and
got hidden and stuff
happened um so it's a journey back in
time and for me this really was I was
sitting like this basically at my desk
I'm like oh my God I wrote this code I
did this um so bear with me in that pain
before we dive into the layers first
stop is the environment because to
understand where these layers came from
at the time you need to understand what
kind of environment we were running in
so it was all on Prim um you you can see
the twoing badges here so we had spark
postgress uh python Druid Scala so quite
a diverse set and in the middle we had
air flow which was orchestrating the
whole thing uh and we had Hadoop so I
think of this stack pretty much all of
them are still around though I would say
Hadoop is Fading Into the background not
too many people are picking it up a new
anymore right now uh I should also note
that we had one Hadoop cluster we had
one Hado cluster 10 nodes one airflow
orchestrator well if he had M and we
were processing 7 billion transactions
multiple times a week so it was a a
challenge
um so data's Inferno so data's Inferno
really was our way of dealing with this
in a constrained environment fixing the
data quality and we sort of made this
diagram uh with all the layers you can
see them I'm not going to read them out
we're going to go past each layer and
check out are these still relevant what
would you do today if you had to apply
this logic this idea um they're ordered
not necessarily in terms of you know you
should start at the first one and then
the second and third more in terms of
complexity so the first one is the
easiest one to implement the last one is
a lot more
complicated so the first one the dag
Integrity test um so everybody here
familiar at least with the ideas of
airflow or written airflow dags I hope
so I see a couple of hands that's good
so everybody's done this right you have
a couple of operators operator one
operator two operator three and you
think great I'm going to push this to
production I'm ready I have my bash
grips bash is ready for production of
course and boom cycle detected in dag
you're like what why is this broken why
is this not
working why this is annoying I've
deployed to production or I've deployed
to an environment and it just blows up
in my face like this and why well we're
lazy developers so we copy paste and the
trick here was that we had spent the
time renaming the variable but forgotten
the parameter it's a class I think
probably everybody that has done airflow
has done something like this in the past
um so we introduced this idea of the dag
Integrity test which was really simple
it would sit in your continuous
integration Pipeline and essentially
what it would do is okay you think
you've written a dag that's valid let me
just quickly check the semantics let me
just quickly validate that that dag is
actually a dag so I'll check you know
does your object make sense is it
missing any required parameters uh and
I'll check for Cycles so this is a small
pseudo code example up here obviously
you can see from uh the way way it looks
the full code is available in the repo
Link at the bottom you'll also be happy
to know I spent some time updating that
repo for 2023 so all of the examples I'm
going to show during the talk now with
the 2023 parallel are in the repo as
well so you can take pictures of course
but the code is there
too um so for each layer I essentially
thought well can we just ask is this
still relevant in 20123 is this
something you would still reasonably
want to do so for this yes I would still
do this it's simple it's easy it's
lightweight and it can just save you
some time you could even integrate it
into a pre-commit hook perhaps to run it
locally before you commit in I think the
ideas are still valid there was a slight
tweak in the Integrity test because the
airflow API changed slightly but the
core is still
there the second one that we in uh the
second layer was more of a conceptual
one um and the idea that we had was to
split data ingestion from data
deployments so again the context was we
were building an app and we were having
airflow deploy the data that the app
needed into the back end uh every I
think twice a week was the schedule um
and initially we just had all the data
sources and all the processing and
transformation in one big dag uh and
that just was annoying uh so at some
point we said look we're going to split
out the ingestion from the deployment um
it wasn't so much a technical thing it
was much more conceptual um what it
allowed us to do was actually say okay
we have separate data ingestion that
means if a source ingestion fails on one
day that's fine the deployment into the
app is decoupled it will still run it
will have old data but that's okay
nothing will break and it won't block
the deployment with the other uh uh data
sources the other thing that it sort of
almost implicitly forced us to do was
Define an interface so we were dealing
with payment transactions but spread out
over all sorts of sources and all these
sources were different systems that
different histories different formats
different types but they were
representing the same business entity so
by doing this we said okay we have an
interface this is what our transactions
interface looks like you always have to
map into that and also by doing that
unlock those data sources for other
users right we were building it for our
app but other app or other developers
were also interested in having this data
in this interface uh shape so it might
seem obvious now that this is the way to
go at the time it wasn't super obvious
at least not to us so still relevant
still thumbs up very yes yes yes very
relevant so so far two out of seven so
we're we're going we're doing
well Layer Three is data tests um so the
example I gave you earlier of the
Hungarian company suddenly being the
most Wealthy on the planet was the sort
of bug that we were regularly encounter
encountering and it was hard because you
would encounter it at the final step of
the dag of of your process and then you
need to sort of breadcrumb trace your
way back in the dag to figure out where
where how did this happen Okay this
table looks okay now this one and this
one and this one it was really painful
and it just cost a lot of time so that
and several other of these incidents
basically said led us to think okay
regardless of how simple and trivial a
task in airflow is every task is going
to have a test task right afterwards so
you can see I hope everybody can see in
the back as well our first task over
there is Union transaction which was
literally a union it doesn't get much
more simple than that in SQL I would say
we would still test like did the number
sort of add up are the for instance is
the union table is it bigger than all of
the source tables it's simple but it
saved us a lot of time so in terms of
implementation back in 2017 this would
look more or less like this we had this
beautiful join uh double left join and
you can see it's SQL but it's wrapped in
spark SQL and then we would save it into
the parket files
essentially not super complex I won't go
over the details of the query but this
is how we did this that was the union of
the the enriched transactions task and
then our test task would look something
like this it would be an assertion based
on a spark SQL query again still SQL
assert that in this case after enriched
transactions we said all of the country
Fields should be filled if they aren't
filled then something has gone wrong in
the enrichment and we need to abort
immediately because that will cause
problems further down the line
um so looking at this some of you might
already have a feeling where I'm going
uh in 2023 there's this tool called DBT
uh that some of you might have heard of
um and it really would have made our
lives so much easier if we would have
had this um you can see the query is the
same so the hard work going into getting
the query right yeah okay we still have
to put that effort in but no more spark
SQL no more spark session configuration
DBT has abstracted away all of that for
us we can just focus on the logic that
we need to implement and structure our
data in the way we
need um the test actually pretty much
the same so the query is slight slightly
different but it's pretty much the same
idea you're still checking are the
country Fields filled if they're not
that's a problem alert abort crash
whatever
fail um I did also check while I was
revamping this uh this setup like could
we have known about DBT back in 2017 so
I looked it up it was around but it was
very sort of alpha not quite ready yet
so that sort of allayed my fears that we
missed something at the
time um so data test 2023 still relevant
uh more thumbs up yes thumbs up or good
uh yeah definitely um I think you know
the form you know do you need to do them
after every Union I would still say it's
worth the extra minute or two that they
just take to run but it saves you so
much pain if something goes wrong
our fourth layer was alerting um I was
looking at this one I was just thinking
this is so obvious like if something
fails you just want to be alerted um but
the way we did it was actually what well
I should rephrase that what was
interesting about alerting is that we
did it in a very sort of direct manner
so we integrated with slack we had our
bot Chuck Norris and Chuck Norris would
just every time a task would faill it
would just post and the message was
really simple it says this Dag is broken
this was the task this was the uh the
time stamp the execution date so you
knew which one was do something I can't
do anything else of course we also
couldn't post straight into slack
because the error message might contain
private details that we didn't want to
share with slack um what was interesting
about this wasn't necessarily only the
technical mechanism but also what it did
with the team so you can see there's a
small icon there and Daniel's up there
that was me telling two of the other
guys like you guys I think you broke
something please take a look but then at
the bottom you also see in slack you see
somebody replying to a message so it
brought this Dynamic where it something
was much more transparent what people
were working on and if you were curious
you could also just look at the logs and
say oh you're struggling with this and
this I know that that's spark executor
memory or something down those lines so
it helped in that way too um so back in
2017 this was
homebuilt uh we we did some uh beautiful
curl I've abstracted away some of the
logic here but we had to get through the
corporate proxy and do all sorts of
token exchanges and it it wasn't that
pretty uh but we did get it to work and
in the end we could just say okay unfill
your call back slack alert send a
message you're Chuck Norris this is the
channel go I'm happy to say that 2023
there's an airflow provider for that uh
the interface is actually pretty much
the same they must have secretly stolen
from us when I wasn't looking um but it
it just works uh this is something I
would just recommend you know if you
have slack if you have teams or some
other chat app that you use your in your
day-to-day use that um but just bring it
in your face we had emails first uh
maybe I'm the only developer that does
this but emails like that I just at
certain point just either actively move
to trash automatically without Outlook
or mentally move to trash at
least um so still relevant yeah at this
point I don't know if I still need any
memes or thumbs up um yes still relevant
still do
it layer five um so it's called git
enforcing the term that we colloquially
used in the team was actually nuclear
git and there was a reason for nuclear
git so it harks back to the context that
we were working in we had one airflow
instance that everything had to run
through so what would sometimes happen
is somebody in the team would need to
work on a feature and they thought they
had everything right and then but then
they said yeah but I really need to run
this through I need to check if the code
will actually execute it give me the
results I wanted but I I need to fiddle
with it a bit um so let me just quickly
take a look they would check out the
code and you know it would fail
obviously that's what would happen they
will fill with more fill with it more
and then at the end of the day they
would go and drink beer and they would
leave the broken code sitting there and
then at sort of 2: a.m. the production
pipeline would kick off and then boom
production pipeline broke
so nuclear git was a thing that ran at
midnight and it would just hard reset
the entire git environment backing airf
flow to whatever was on the main branch
at the
time um that was painful and we had a
few occasions where people actually lost
work but it did ensure that production
was stayed working that was our main
focus but also it bred in this idea that
your code must be in git if these people
would have checked their code into git
they wouldn't have lost their their code
so that's sort of where the idea of git
enforcing came from why we were doing
this still relevant in 2023 that's the
question and you think for me this one
is a no uh this really was a quirk of
the environment that we were working in
it was a way to somehow get control uh
if you really want to look for sort of a
glimmer of something that you still have
back from 2018 it's that you need to be
in control of what's running in each
environment and it should be inversion
control I wouldn't take this approach
though
so layer six is the idea of mock
pipeline tests um so in in a sense data
is Inferno is like this swiss cheese
model right you know that your each
slice of cheese is going to have holes
in it but by adding and stacking layers
and layers and layers on top of each
other you're going to block off a lot of
holes and you're going to catch the
errors so why am I referencing this now
is while the mock pipeline test sits in
the middle of the stack of cheese so you
first have your unit test checking is
the code you know will this do what I
think it would do and then on the other
side you have your data tests which will
run on real data during the process sort
of at run time when your pipeline is
running the mark pipeline tests sit in
between should run in your CI and
essentially they will run through a
marked version of your entire pipeline
it's almost an integration test we call
them mock pipeline test at the at the
time that was the the conceptually how
we were thinking so what does that look
like you generate some data um back in
2017 so in this case Donald duck was
apparently wanting to transfer some
money and we had our pipeline a
referenced filter data and essentially
at the end you want to say okay I just
want to make sure that Donald Duck is no
longer in there it's similar to the data
test but it's dummy data so you can be
really specific you can say I this
account I know for a fact cannot be in
there rather than sort of at the higher
aggregate level sometimes you can reuse
the
testone so this was back in
2017 back in 2023 three we can still use
DBT for this so you could in our case uh
I looked at integrating other tooling uh
uh sort of the unit testing packages
that are available for DBT but found
actually using native Native DBT at the
time that would have got us got us to
the point that we got without DBT as
well so I'm interested in exploring more
is what these other unit testing
packages of DBT would bring on top or
perhaps even tools like soda or Great
Expectations could add into the mix as
well um again you know your data
generation that's something that you
still need to do call your logic run
your logic and then um run your test it
seems simple but it saves you especially
if you run this in your CI because it
will catch things at commit time ideally
if it's not too big you could even run
in a
pre-commit so still relevant yes uh
definitely still
relevant so it's a good thing that we're
at lar 7 because we're running out of
time so layer seven was conceptually the
most complicated one especially given we
had one Hadoop cluster one airflow
environment we were doing daap um so the
core idea of daap is you're going to
create separate environments with
separate sets of data or at least
subsets of their full data set for
specific purpose so in our case we had
four we had development test acceptance
production classic mapping of what
people have been doing for years in
let's say the more devops application uh
uh uh
World um in Dev we would do a random
sample just to validate does anything
even work in test we had a handpicked
sample to make sure that the logic could
actually link certain entities together
acceptance was a carbon copy so the
entire data set was there and production
was production so the quirky thing that
we did in 2017 was we we had this idea
of we have one airflow and then every
environment was essentially another
airflow pipeline or airf flow dag and
development if it succeeded would
trigger test test it succeeded would
trigger acceptance and then between
acceptance and production there was a
manual approval just to make sure like
you sure you want to roll this out to
production in 2023 I think realistically
the idea of using one airflow is uh well
let's say living on the edge I would
always say split it out a bit um and do
this deployment between the dags with
Git or some sort of cicd flow uh
depending on what you want this also
opens up the possibility of checking
airf flow upgrades uh I remember
sometimes that in at the time we had to
do an airflow upgrade and that just was
fingers crossed and let's hope for the
best because we don't quite know if
everything will be okay and then I
remember a couple of cases where they
had renamed the operators and then you
have to go over all the dags to rename
The Operators so that was uh was
fun so still relevant in
2023 yes but no would be what I would
say uh yes in the sense that dedicated
environments will help you yes yes in a
sense you need that separation to be
operate able to operate freely to check
things out to do things no in a sense
I'm not sure I would do four full
environments I think that's a bit much
uh and you need to balance it with how
much it costs how big your data is um
there's a quite a high price if you have
seven billion transactions to do a full
copy um and I think you need to figure
out is that worth it and do you need
four environments this thing is here as
well is it's not just a oneof copy right
of produ to acceptance you need to keep
that data set up to date because
otherwise there's not much point then
your data on acceptance would be out of
date and wouldn't contain the same
quirks that production now
has so we've gone through hell we're
still here um and I just figured okay
let's what is still relevant what are we
where are we at right now so I think
where we're at is that we can say the
data Integrity test the ingestion split
data test alerting and mock plan tests
those are relevant I think those yeah
you need some tweaking there's some
tooling that you might want to change CH
you know the tooling has evolved I'm
glad to say um but they're still okay
dap yes but I would change that quite
substantially more than I would change
the other any of the others um get
enforcing yeah no I wouldn't go there
anymore but if we take a step back right
what are we actually talking about here
I mean there's a quirky names there are
memes but underlying the names
underlying the memes is actually some
core
ideas so we're actually mapping if you
take a look at these tasks you can
probably mentally map them to some of
the concepts on the right you can say
we're talking about code integrity and
validity right with the uh dag Integrity
tests we're talking about pipeline
structure again dag Integrity tests but
also the ingestion split perhaps data
quality covered in your data test your
mock pipeline tests alerting no need to
add anymore and your separation of
concerns so I think those are really The
Core Concepts that you still 6 years old
are still valid so I now have kids as
well and I just projected my kids saying
please Dad can we now leave hell are we
finished are we nearly there yet so I
think working with real data can still
be hard um it's hard to know what to
test um it's hard to always catch all of
the errors I think it's just something
you constantly need to work on because
Fiel data constantly surprises you that
was the case in 2017 and I think it's
still the case now in 201 23 the tooling
is so much better at though as I said
having DBT at the time would have saved
us so much time so I'm really happy to
say that the stuff we did at the time
with spark jobs and Spark SQL that we
wouldn't do that this way anymore um so
in that sense tooling is much much
better um looking forward I think the
tooling can still improve a bit but what
I really hope to see is that those three
points there can get automated a bit
more that we don't need to all do this
manual work of figuring out what to test
that we can get some sort of insight
some sort of suggestion maybe maybe some
profiling ideas chat DBT anyone
something that can help us a bit to get
started so with that I'd like to thank
you very much for your attention again
this the GitHub link so please check it
out and happy to take any
questions